Để chủ động ứng phó báo số mùi một, sở sây dự hà nội vừa ban hành công văn đôn đốc cơ đơn vị,
dở, ngành, bị bán nhân dân cắt sát, phương văn dân nghiệp dịch vụ hạt tân khẩn chương trường
chiếc hai phương án phòng, chống thiên tài theo tinh thần chủ đậu, sáng sáng ứng chực kì thời.
Cũng thế, công ty thát nước hà nội tăng cường kiểm soát bảo đam tự thoát tại diểm uống gặp,
hà mực nước hồ điều hà, kinh mường.
Công viên kê sang trẳng chống, cắt tiền ứng chực sử li cây gãi đồ.
Đơn vị cấp nước chuẩn bị xe bôn, bể chứ dự phòng, công ty chêu sáng suy trị tối thiệu
chỉ mấy tám phân chăm hệ thống, sử li sự cố bảo đam án tòa đệt.
Chúng tâm còn li hạ tân kiết thật sám sát, tổng hợp, báo cáo, bị bán nhân dân cơ sở chiếc hai bốn tại chổ,
sở nông nghiệp và môi trường chỉ đạo bân hà mực nước hỗ trợ đủ thiện.
Theo chung tâm khi tự thiện vàn Quốc sát, dự báo trong những ngày tới báo sẽ anh vừa chực tiếp đến khu vực đất liền trong đó có thủ đô hà nội.